they make it their business to mind your
business Burlington Iowa wants to ban
the open carry of guns toy guns it's
going to be a matter of time until we
actually end up with a confrontation
with somebody that has a gun that's
maybe not real real gun or not rest easy
knowing that the police believe that a
confrontation is only a matter of time
in an Oakland California going green and
making grin just got a little harder
because the city has banned ecoatm s
it's a machine that analyzes your old
thing and if you accept shells add money
never mind recycling the City
Councilwoman says cash payouts from the
machines incentivize people to steal
cell phones we think that something must
be done to reduce cell phone back yes
something must be done like perhaps
enforcing existing laws against robbery
but this month's top prize goes to
Newport Beach California where officials
have banned new businesses from renting
out awesome jetpacks like these city
lawmakers put a moratorium on new
licenses which attack related businesses
citing concerns related to noise
excessive wakes and safety and it starts
right now ok so safety might be an issue
for some but the rest of us have been
waiting for our jet packs for a very
long time and we don't want dopey local
news reporters keeping us grounded and
everybody could slap
follow nanny month on Twitter submit
your nanny nominees and check back next
month for more examples of busybodies
minding your own business